[Musik]
er ist 24 jahre jung war tomas galasek
als ihn der damalige tschechische
präsident václav havel als finanzanalyst
und berater in die prager burg holte
heute ist er 34 und chefökonom der
größten tschechischen bank zieht lattek
ein schlauer kopf mit einem ganz eigenen
blick auf die wirtschaft das macht ihn
sperrig faszinierend und erfolgreich
sein buch die ökonomie von gut und böse
eben auch auf deutsch erschienen ist ein
bestseller
auch in finanzkreisen salatic geht der
ökonomie auf den grund eher suchten den
frühen mythen in der religion und
philosophie
nach den ersten zeugnissen unseres
leistungs nicht zuletzt nach den
kulturellen wurzeln unserer gier thomas
schlagzeug war gerade mit am wef in
davos katrin teenager möchte jetzt
natürlich von dem unter anderem wissen
ob und wie seine sichtweise dort
aufgenommen wurde
thomas maczek sie kommen gerade aus
davos sie waren am wef sie haben dort
mit anderen experten über die erneuerung
des kapitalismus diskutiert konnten sie
etwas erreichen
wir haben erreicht dass dieses thema
ernst genommen wird
das ist ein riesiger schritt zudem
beginnen alle oder die meisten zuzugeben
dass sie nicht verstehen was momentan
passiert
auch das ist ein gewaltiger fortschritt
wenn sie sich eingestehen können dass
sie etwas das sie zu verstehen glaubten
nicht verstehen ist das ein gewaltiger
schritt und für die wirtschaft völlig
einmal dass in diesem mekka des
kapitalismus der geschäftsleute und des
wohlstands über erneuerungen diskutiert
und versucht wurde neue
wirtschaftsmodelle zu finden sehe ich
als großen erfolg
tatsache ist dass solche dinge viel zeit
erfordern
es wird lange dauern bis wir wissen ob
das überhaupt kapitalismus ist das ist
nicht klar
wir verhalten uns oft sehr kommunistisch
aber lieber den grünen themen
vor zehn jahren waren sie noch sehr
marginal
hätten wir damals hier gesessen hätte
ich ihnen nicht geglaubt wenn sie mir
gesagt hätten dass zehn jahre später
unternehmen das klima zum hauptthema
machen würden
wir müssen als auch hier geduldig sein
denn es geht darum das ganze
wirtschaftsmodell zu überdenken und das
brauche zeit
die ökonomie hätte nun endlich bemerkt
dass sie auch dunkle seiten hat die sie
angehen muss haben sie denn wirkliches
gefühl dass diese leute in davos reif
sind für neue modelle
ich glaube dass dieses thema haben sie
selber gewählt ob sie sehr kreativ sein
werden oder nicht ist eine andere frage
es ist lustig stellen sie sich vor
jemand baut für sie ein haus und das
bricht zusammen
sie bitten ihn es wieder aufzubauen und
es bricht erneut zusammen und das zehn
mal beim elften mal geben sie den
auftrag natürlich jemand andere aus
so ähnlich ist es mit uns ökonomen wir
haben etwas gebaut und es hat nicht
funktioniert
wir wurden gebeten es zu reparieren und
wir tun so als verstünden was passiert
ist aber vielleicht müssen wir eine neue
methode anwendungen
womöglich sind die bisherigen methoden
zb die mathematik die so
wissenschaftlich daher kommt nicht so
nützlich wie wir meinten und wir sollten
wir auch philosophen soziologen und
anthropologen hören oder vielleicht
sogar auf künstler oder die leute welche
die wall street
denn sie sagen niemand habe die krise
vorausgesagt aber das stimmt nicht
wenn sie hören was soziologen
philosophen und anthropologen sagen oder
die leute die auf der straße gegen den
weltwährungsfonds und die weltbank
protestieren
vieles was sie kritisieren die düsteren
seiten der globalisierung usw wollten
wir nie wahrhaben
wir hatten das glück oder unglück das
sich die globalisierung in den letzten
20 jahren von der sonnigen seite zeigte
und erst jetzt kommen auch die
schattenseiten des kapitalismus zum
vorschein
der trick ist das gute zu nehmen und das
schlechte wegzulassen
das gute mit dem schlechten zu zerstören
ich denke das system des kapitalismus
ist reformierbar
ich komme aus der früheren
tschechoslowakei
dort hatten wir 1968 eine kommunistische
perestroika eine art vermenschlichung
des kommunismus
das funktionierte nicht wir mussten das
ganze system zerstören
nun wird die gleiche thematik wieder
aufgegriffen vor allem von philosophen
die frage ist eine kapitalistische
perestroika möglich denn heute ist von
unseren menschlicher kapitalismus
gefordert und wir müssen schauen ob das
machbar ist oder ob das ganze system
geändert werden muss und wenn sie danach
fragen ob das möglich ist sie sind ja
ein heftiger kritiker der ökonomie sie
sind ja selber ökonom sie haben das fach
studiert sie arbeiten in diesem fach sie
treten auf als ökonomen in der
tschechischen regierung als chefökonom
einer bank und trotzdem stellen sie das
so sehr in frage stellen sie denn auch
ihre eigene kompetenz infrage
jetzt neue modelle zu eruieren natürlich
und das tun wir doch alle sie nicht wenn
sie eine suppe kochen und nicht sicher
sind ob sie gut wird
das müssen wir tun es wäre nicht
hilfreich wenn ich ein mönch wäre und
tief im wald oder hoch oben auf einem
berg in einer höhle meditierte
kakerlaken essen und den leuten zurief
was ihr tut ist falsch natürlich
kritisiere ich mich hier selbst es ist
besser wenn derjenige der im system drin
ist sich fragt warum tue ich das
warum studieren wir dies und nicht das
natürlich ich bin voller widersprüche
das war ich schon immer ich denke das
ist jeder mensch kennen sie nicht auch
diese stimme die sagt tue das und wenn
sie es getan haben fragt eine andere
stimme warum hast du das getan
vielleicht wäre dass andere besser
solche überlegungen stehen jedoch
ständig
bei mir war es so dass ich tagsüber als
ökonom berechnungen machte und prognosen
und analysen erstellt
und am abend bei einem glas wein las
sich philosophische bücher und stellte
mir die nacht fragen die langsameren
kontemplativen fragen macht das was sie
tagsüber tat und daraus aus der nach der
wirtschaft gleichsam entstand dieses
buch in dem ich das hinter frage was er
tagsüber tun und die dunklen seiten sind
die nächte der ökonomie diese allegorie
funktioniert nicht der abend gibt raum
für kontemplation
tagsüber habe ich oft keine zeit über
dinge nachzudenken das tue ich am abend
denn es ist wichtig für mich und ich
hätte nie gedacht dass ich die beiden
dinge miteinander verknüpfen würde würde
als die krise begann wurde ich dinge
gefragt auf die ich keine standard
antworten hat was ist der unterschied
zwischen preis und wert und was haben
sie ganz haben konnten nicht antworten
heute können sie antworten ja denn dort
hat die wirtschaft angefangen beim
unterschied zwischen wert und preis die
beiden begriffe scheinen ähnlich aber
sie sind total verschieden
nehmen wir ein beispiel die wirtschaft
behauptet eine wertfreie wert neutrale
wissenschaft zu sein doch wir haben
ständig mit preisen und werten zu tun
wie kann die wirtschaft behaupten
wertfrei zu sein wenn man analysten am
fernsehen sagen hört der goldpreis ist
überbewertet oder der goldpreis ist
unterbewertet oder der euro ist
gegenüber dem dollar unterbewertet
solche dinge hört man ständig was der
preis ist
ich sage es anders wert ist etwas sehr
sowie knie und kennt den wahren wert von
gold
wir kennen nur seinen preis sagt er
etwas wunderbares einen zyniker erkennt
man daran dass er von jedem ding den
preis aber von keinem habt so auch so
auch in der wirtschaft es mir fragen
kennen wir von jedem ding den preis aber
von
einen den wert ich denke das ist ein
fundamentales problem der wirtschaft in
unserem leben gibt es viele dinge die
wert haben einige dieser werte haben
einen preis andere werte haben keinen
preis
dieser stift zum beispiel ist sehr
wertvoll für mich und er hat einen preis
ich könnte ihn an sie verkaufen und mir
einen neuen kaufen dieses glas hat einen
preis diese tisch hat einen preis
dann gibt es dinge die einen wert aber
keinen preis haben schönheit liebe
freundschaft saubere luft das leiden von
tieren das leiden von menschen
auch dafür haben wir keinen preis die
schönheit unsere städte und andere
qualitäten die man nicht in zahlen
messen kann
die alle verstehen dass diese werte
existieren aber nur ein teil davon
preise haben auch eine noch so
komplizierte kalkulation kann das nicht
ändern denn das resultat für gewisse
werte kann kein preis keine zahl sein
die ganze frage stellung hin dass etwas
einen preis hat heißt nicht dass es
besser oder vergleichbar ist mit dem was
keinen preis hat das gilt für alles auch
wenn ich diesen stift kaufe spielen
werte mit denen wichtig sind und keinen
preis haben
da scheint das hauptproblem der
wirtschaft zu sein wenn sie versucht
exakte resultate zu liefern
diese dinge kann man genau berechnen
nehmen wir den zins der zinssatz hat mit
vertrauen zu tun wenn ich ihnen
vertrauen schenke leitlinien geld zu
einem kleinen zinssatz wenn ich ihnen
nicht vertrauen müssen sie mir einen
sehr hohen zins bezahlen
nehmen wir das beispiel von griechenland
dass es bekannt
wir wussten dass der zinssatz für
griechische staatsanleihen 4,42 prozent
betrug wir tun hier als etwas
metaphysisch
wir versuchen unseren glauben unser
vertrauen unsere hoffnung auf zahlen zu
setzen und das ist eine sehr genaue zahl
bis auf zwei stellen nach dem komma 4,42
prozent das ist sehr präzise auf den
hundertstel genau den zinssatz kann man
also genau berechnen aber dieser war
falsch heute wissen wir dass der
zinssatz für griechische anleihen fiel
höher hätte sein sollen
wir konnten ihn zwar berechnen aber die
zahl bedeutete nichts und das problem
war das ganze war ein schwindel ein
spiel das nicht funktionierte warum bei
der berechnung des zinssatzes ist ein
faktor die pleite wahrscheinlichkeit und
dagegen sich hat man sich mit einer
kreditausfallversicherung
sagen wir ich lange griechenland geld
ich kalkuliere wie hoch das risiko ist
dass das land bankrott geht dann sichere
ich mich ab sollte griechenland
pleitegehen zahlen sie mir so viel
das nennt man eine
kreditausfallversicherung funktioniert
perfekt wunderbar und in jedem fall
außer im fall eines bankrotts
dann stimmt nichts mehr es ist als
würden sie ein tolles auto fahren mit
einem airbag der immer funktioniert
außer bei einem unfall
wir hatten eine sehr genaue zahl 4,42
prozent
aber die zahl war falsch die dann
funktioniert wenn alles gut geht und
wenn alles so geht wie ist die modelle
rechnen und in dem moment wo wir in
einer krise stecken hat die ökonomie
keine antwort mehr
wir können einzig sagen was auch für die
demokratie gilt kapitalismus
funktioniert wenn er funktioniert und er
funktioniert nicht wenn er nicht
funktioniert auch demokratie
funktioniert wenn sie funktioniert und
manchmal funktioniert sie einfach nicht
mehr das problem hier ist komplizierter
wir wissen nicht in welcher situation
wir sind wir wissen nicht ob der
kapitalismus funktioniert oder nicht
ich weiß nicht ob sie das auch canon auf
tschechisch sagen wir theoretisch
funktioniert das aber in der praxis
nicht
eigentlich sollten wir das umkehren in
der praxis funktioniert es in der
theorie nicht das ist das problem der
wissenschaft etwas fällt zu boden
das ist die praxis aber theoretisch kann
man es auch mit der ausgeklügelten
fanden für sieg nicht voll und ganz
erklären
wir sehen dass die dinge herunterfallen
aber wir wissen nicht genau warum und
die wissenschaft ist dazu da solche
dinge theoretisch zu erklären die frage
wäre jetzt wenn sie sagen dass die
ökonomie zwar nach der zahl sucht aber
mit der zahl eigentlich nicht den punkt
findet der getroffen werden muss wäre ja
nun die frage muss die ökonomie noch
genauer werden muss sie daran arbeiten
die noch genauere zahl zu finden
oder muss sich die ökonomie umgekehrt
von der zahl entfernen
viele meiner kollegen glauben das erste
co2 ausstoß ist ein beispiel wir haben
den wert saubere luft
der hat keinen preis also legen wir mit
der co2 emission einem preis fest dort
ist das ein gewisser fortschritt aber
ich würde eher in die andere richtung
gehen denn die wahrheit liegt nicht in
den zahlen
ich gebe ihnen ein beispiel ich weiß
nicht ob sie per anhalter durch die
galaxis von douglas adams kennen
ich erzähle kurz den inhalt die menschen
wollen die antwort auf die ultimative
frage nach dem leben dem universum und
dem ganzen rest finden sie bauen einen
gigantischen computer und das dauert
millionen jahre in der zwischenzeit
streiken die philosophen aus angst sie
würden arbeitslos wenn die frage nach
dem sinn des lebens beantwortet ist
nach ein paar millionen jahren sagte
computer jetzt habe ich die antwort auf
die frage nach dem leben dem universum
und dem ganzen rest
das multiversum versammelt sich unter
computer sagt ich habe es mehrmals
geprüft es gibt keinen zweifel die
antwort ist 42
alle sind schockiert denn das macht
keinen sinn
und darauf hin dass adams hinaus die
zahl hat keine bedeutung die wahrheit
entschlüsselt sich aus dem zusammenhang
und der witz ist dass niemand weiß wie
die frage genau lautet
aber das wollen wir frage ich meine
studenten nach waren aussagen kommen sie
mit mathematik 1 und 12 sie sagen nie
ich liebe meine freundin oder ich hatte
ein gutes frühstück oder heute ist das
kalt etwas in uns vielleicht ist das die
erziehung lässt uns glauben in zahlen
ausgedrückte aussagen sein wahrer als
solche ohne zahlen
es ist jetzt die frage der wahrheit die
sie jetzt da antippen die auch versucht
eine objektivierung herzubekommen also
die die einschätzung ob es eine wahrheit
ist dass ich meiner liebsten liebe oder
nicht das ist eine individuelle
entscheidung und der versuch das sind
eine zahl zu fassen ist der versuch
einer objektivierung und das ist ja doch
auch nützlich für die gesellschaft zu
wissen in etwa ja worauf wir uns stützen
können auf welche gesetzmäßigkeiten auf
welche regelmäßigkeit und das ist ja
auch ein wesentlicher teil der ökonomie
aber in ihrem leben tun sie das nicht
oder wissen sie ob sie 4,2 mal
glücklicher sind als letztes jahr
sehen sie wissen sie überhaupt ob sie
das ist der seltsame trick den wir
anwenden sie leben die beziehungen mit
ihren liebsten nicht in mathematischen
formeln
tatsache ist wenn es um persönliche
beziehungen geht wollen wir es plötzlich
nicht mehr so genau nehmen wir das
trinkgeld im restaurant ökonomisch
gesehen macht das keinen sinn
meine interpretation ist ich runde auf
geld bedeutet mir nichts ich lade sie
diesmal einen sieger haben nicht das
nächste mal ein
aber ich sage nicht machen halbe-halbe
nicht nur so als ob gelb nicht existiert
wir tun so als würde genauigkeit nicht
existieren deshalb über male ich den
preis auf einem geschenk natürlich
wissen sie wie viel es kostet aber es
wäre eine beleidigung wenn sie den
genauen preis lesen würden nehmen wir an
wir sind befreundet und ich bitte sie
mir beim transport eines sofas zu helfen
sie sagen zu nach einer stunde sind wir
fertig und ich sage vielen dank ihr sind
126 euro
das würde sie beleidigen würde ich sie
aber für diesen preis zum essen einladen
oder innen zwei flaschen wein schenken
sie akzeptieren natürlich würden wir
dann diesen kleinen tanz machen wäre
nicht nötig ist es doch und schließlich
würden sie es akzeptieren aber die
genaue somit nicht das gleiche gilt wenn
wir etwas essen oder trinken gehen und
ich sie einladen oder sie sagen gut ich
trinke ein glas rotwein und ich hier
sind acht franken
was ist so viel kostete 1
was macht es aus ob ich das geld im
keller oder ihnen gebe es wäre
beleidigend weil es eine genaue zahl ist
wenn der kellner die rechnung bringt
machte das sehr diskret und versteckt
damit sie den genauen betrag nicht sehen
in unseren beziehungen sind wir also
ungenauer jemand hat mal sehr schön
gesagt freunde sind menschen die
einander so viel schulden dass sie den
überblick verloren haben also quasi die
ökonomie sollst von diesen zählen von
dieser genauigkeit wegkommen und sollte
stattdessen wie sie ja in ihrem buch die
ökonomie von gut und böse auch schildern
sollte zurück auf ihre wurzeln gehen und
sie suchen diese wurzeln ja sehr weit
zurück sie gehen bis zum gilgamesch epos
zurück der 4000 jahre vor unserer zeit
liegt was finden sie denn dafür ein ich
sage nicht dass wir die mathematik sein
lassen sollen
sie ist ein teil der wirtschaft und hat
ihre legitimation solange sie resultate
liefert ich finde zwar das tut sie nicht
aber das ist glaubenssache
wenn jemand katholische ökonom ist und
an polstern müssen glaubt kann er das
tun
aber er soll bitte niemand anderen dazu
zwingen das ist der trick der wirtschaft
service und theorie ist die bibel der
ökonomie die nach dem krieg jeder
angehende ökonom studieren musste in
seiner volkswirtschaftslehre die eine
wahre bibel für ökonomen ist schreibt er
in diesem buch lernt er wie ein ökonom
zu denken und das ist einer seiner
tricks ich liebe ihn aber er ist sehr
heimtückisch da geht es um ideologie das
hat nichts mit wissenschaft zu tun
denken die ein ökonom
da muss man sofort fragen wie welche
keynes schon peter marx oder milton
friedman
ist sein trick er hätte sagen sollen ihr
lärm denken wie paulson das wäre legitim
aber wie kann er sagen mein denken ist
ein mann hatte ich ein gespräch mit
einem älteren professor der nicht fragte
was tun sie mit unserer wirtschaft ich
fragte zurück seit wann gehört die
wirtschaft ihnen bei allem respekt sie
haben die wirtschaft nicht gepachtet und
sie beschränkt sich nicht auf ein buch
wir brauchen die wirtschafts mathematik
aber nicht nur die österreichische
schule verzichtet darauf dann haben wir
die deutsche schule
es gibt viele verschiedene schulen alle
haben ihre berechtigung im moment
wichtigste zu sein
richtig und wie lernt man philosophie
man studiert die geschichte der
philosophie
niemand sagt den studenten diese
philosophie ist die richtige whitehead
platt oder aristoteles das tut man auch
nicht in der soziologie oder in der
politologe aber im wirtschaftsstudium
ist die mainstream ökonomie die einzige
wahrheit und nachdem du sie drei jahre
lang studiert hast ist ein glaube daran
stark dann zeigen sie dir dass es auch
andere religionen gibt aber sie sind
weniger wichtig diesen ökonomen legen
sie nun diese bibel vor und sagen ihnen
über die ökonomie was sie noch nicht
wussten nun eher das gegenteil wie im
umgang mit meinen studenten ich lehre
sie nichts ich versuche sie zu entleeren
in unserem unterricht sieht das so aus
drei jahre lang lernen die studenten die
wirtschaftsmodelle funktionieren dann
behandeln die paradoxie in der
verhaltensökonomie gibt es paradoxe
verhaltensweisen zum beispiel dass
menschen sich gegenseitig beschenken das
ist aus wirtschaftlicher sicht paradox
aber nicht für normale menschen nur für
jemanden der drei jahre lang orthodoxe
ökonomie studiert hat und dann braucht
er zwei jahre um zu realisieren dass das
ganze nicht funktioniert
so etwas hat das also genützt wenn er
nicht drei jahre lang diesen glauben
praktiziert hätte würde etwas wie
schenken nicht paradox klingen
[Musik]
ich will etwas aufzeigen
viele denken dass unsere vorfahren dumm
wenn wir klug sind in diesem buch
versuche ich genau das gegenteil zu
beweisen
nämlich wie viele kluge dinge einige von
ihnen gesagt und getan haben im
vergleich zu unserem heutigen verhalten
dgb haus oder im alten testament findet
man vieles das man heute als wirtschaft
bezeichnen würde zum beispiel meine
lieblingsgeschichte genesis kapitel 41
das ist die erste historisch
aufgezeichnete geschichte über einen
konjunkturzyklus jeder kennt die
geschichte aber nur wenige stehen diesen
bezug her
der ägyptische pharao sieht im traum sie
um fette kühe und sieben magere kühe und
bittet josef in den traum zu deuten
das ist ganz klar ein konjunkturzyklus
josef gratulierte
das ist eine makroökonomische vorhersage
14 jahre vor der zeit
du wirst sieben jahre überfluss und
sieben jahre ruhe haben wollte würde er
sagen staatsschulden und der fragt was
soll ich tun
welche fiskalpolitik empfiehlst du und
josef sagt sehr weise ist nicht alles
was in den guten jahren wächst spare ein
wenig fülle die vorratskammern in
schlechten jahren kannst du dann den
konsum steigern damit die menschen nicht
verhungern
bis das lehrt uns viele erster das
bruttoinlandsprodukt nicht ständig zu
erhöhen sondern die ausschläge des
konjunkturzyklus auszugleichen
die zweite wichtige lektion ist dass
sich die wirtschaft wie ein
manisch-depressiver verhält doch unsere
diagnose ist falsch alle sagen wir
befinden uns in einer
wirtschaftsdepression ich sage das ist
eine fehldiagnose wir sind nicht
depressiv
sondern manisch depressiv das ist ein
gewaltiger unterschied denn
manisch-depressive therapiert man anders
vor allem behandelt man zuerst die man
ihn auch wir erlebten manische zeiten
vor der krise zb ein gigantisches
wachstum
symptome für eine manie sind man glaubt
an die zukunft
man gibt viel mehr geld aus als man hat
dann sieht alles rosig und kann sich
nicht vorstellen dass er eine wolke den
blauen himmel trüben wird und sehr
interessant in der money ist man äußerst
kreativ und effizient man brennt
sozusagen aus das ist auch die beste
beschreibung für unsere
wirtschaftssituation vor der krise und
nun konzentrieren sich alle auf die
depression
aber das gehört zusammen wenn ein
depressiver positiver denkt und sich
seine stimmung aufhellt sind das gute
neuigkeiten fühlt sich ein
manisch-depressiver besser ist das nicht
nur positiv denn seine stimmung kann
schnell wieder kippen
manisch depressiven gibt man medikamente
welche die stimmung schwankungen
ausgleichen
also eine ähnliche maßnahme wie in der
geschichte des alten testaments
testament man hätte eigentlich den 90er
jahren und vor der krise hätte man
dieses wachstum ganz also vor allem den
2000er jahren hätte man dieses wachstum
ganz bewusst lassen müssen
hätte man diese josef schregel wie sie
sie nennen dann schon beherzigt genau
und das ist die ironie josef brauchte
keine mathematischen wirtschaftsmodelle
keine wissenschaftlichen überlegungen
und abstrakten konstruktionen um das zu
sehen
interessanterweise brauchte er nichts
von dem was unsere
wirtschaftswissenschaft ausmacht heute
schließen jedes jahr hunderttausende
ökonomen nach sechs jahren ihr studium
ab sie bekommen die beste ausbildung
aber diesen wichtigen punkt sieht
niemand wir meinten tatsächlich wie
manisch depressive es würde immer nach
oben und nach unten gehen wir wissen
eigentlich dass wir nicht mehr ausgeben
können als wir einnehmen
trotzdem tun mir ist die ganze zeit
und das ist nun die schuld der ökonomie
weil sie das zu sehr in eine
wissenschaft packt und uns damit glauben
macht dass das korrekt ist
das heißt haben wir den zugang zu
einfachen regeln verloren
jaja wissenschaft ist eine ideologie
gewisse leute gehen sogar weiter und
behaupten sie sei eine religion
sie erlaubt einem dinge die man
normalerweise nicht tun würde die
schulden zu machen und das ist das
wunderbare beim deutschen begriff schuld
bedeutet auch sünde gleich wie in latein
griechisch ungarisch in diesen sprachen
entsprechend schuld und sünde sich warum
schulden ermöglichen uns zu sündigen
wenn ich so viel will und nur so viel
habe ist das nicht erlaubt das kann ich
nicht aber dank schulden kann ich viel
mehr haben als zulässig ist salman
rushdie sagte einmal jede sünde ist ein
unzulässiges verhalten auch etwas zu
kaufen das ich mir nicht leisten kann
ist unzulässig ist das muss man nicht
wörtlich nehmen weiß man dass man am
nächsten tag so viel verdient und die
differenz zurück bezahlen kann ist das
okay aber nur wenn man damit rechnen
kann
es ist ähnlich wie mit alkohol alkohol
gibt ihnen nicht mehr energie er
verschiebt diese nur ein kredit der
nichts anderes ist als eine
zeitverschiebung von energie und geld
wie zeitreisende in einem science
fiction film kann geld eine zeitreise
machen und das nennt man kredit und zins
alkohol macht etwas ähnliches mit
unserer energie nicht über lange zeit
sondern über ein oder zwei tage zu
verbringen wenn freitagabend in einer
war sprühen vor energie und singen alles
ist schön und wunderbar
sie haben angeregte gespräche sind
lustig und tanzen bis in den morgen es
wäre falsch zu denken diese zusätzliche
energie komme vom alkohol
das einzige was alkohol bewirkt er
verschiebt die energie vom samstagmorgen
auf den freitagabend aber die wochenend
energie ist konstant sie wird einfach
vorverschoben richtig und es ist egal
sich an einem freitagabend zu betrinken
wenn man am samstag nichts wichtiges
vorhat das kann man voraussehen
wenn man sich aber am sonntagabend
betrinkt und am montag etwas wichtiges
vorhat weit reisen muss oder eine
wichtige besprechung geplant hat ist das
einfach dumm so könnten wir die krise
deuten wir sind an einem sehr wichtigen
tag mit einem kater aufgewacht
das problem mit schulden ist diese
verschiebung der zeit energie über zehn
oder 40 jahren
denn man kann unmöglich vorhersehen wie
die lage in 40 jahren sein werde während
sie bei alkoholgenuss vorhersehen können
was am nächsten tag in ihrem leben
passiert wir müssen also vorsichtig jede
energie die wir verbrauchen jedes
defizit was er machen muss zurückgezahlt
werden
aber so finanzieren sich regierungen und
oft bleibt dabei der gesunde
menschenverstand auf der strecke wenn
sie an den kredit von 10.000 schweizer
franken aufnehmen würde nur ein
verrückter behaupten dass sie
zehntausend franken reicher sind für das
wäre dumm wenn eine regierung das
gleiche tut applaudieren alle auch sehr
gebildete ökonomen ein beispiel die
regierung hat ein defizit von 3 prozent
und nimmt also anleihen für drei prozent
des bruttoinlandsproduktes auf
angenommen in diesem jahr wächst das
bruttoinlandsprodukt um 3 prozent alle
applaudieren und denken wir seien reiche
aber es ist als würde man ihnen sagen
sie seien reicher weil sie einen kredit
über 10000 franken aufgenommen haben was
würden sie erzählen
das ist eine sehr schöne geschichte
die ich auch ökonomisch lese die
erbsünde wurde oft sexuell interpretiert
vor allem im mittelalter auf darstellung
in jener zeit sieht man zwei nackte
menschen in einem garten und kann seine
fantasie spielen lassen
aber es geht nicht um sex oder
geschlechtsverkehr das einzige wort das
sich mal wiederholt wird ist es
ökonomisch ausgedrückt konsumieren als
ökonom ist für mich die erbsünde also
weniger sexuelles begehren sondern
vielmehr die erste sünde des konsums und
zwar die sünde übermäßigen konsums denn
adam und eva mussten diese frucht nicht
essen
offensichtlich waren sie nicht hungrig
und der fluch die vertreibung aus dem
paradies erfolgte derzeit gott sagte ich
habe euch alles gegeben ihr wart perfekt
hat alles mangelte es an nichts aber ihr
wart nicht glücklich ihr wolltet mehr
konsumieren
ihr wart unzufrieden und ihr werdet nie
zufrieden sein
das ist eure stadt so liest ein ökonom
die schöpfungsgeschichte die schlange
weckt in eva den fluch des begehrens du
wirst wollen du wirst begehren aber das
begehren wird nicht hier sein sondern
irgendwo da oben und immer vor dir
herrennen und adam wird mit dem fluch
der versorgung belegt im schweiße deines
angesichts erster arbeiten trotz
technologien und neuen errungenschaften
wirst du immer im schweiße deines
angesichts arbeiten denn es wird nie
genug sein um ihr oder dein begehren zu
befriedigen
ähnlich wie das was tyler durden in
chuck pelly next roman veith klappt sagt
wir tun arbeiten die wir hassen damit
wir dinge kaufen können die wir nicht
brauchen
das ist in etwa der fluch von adam und
eva es gibt auch einen schönen
philosophisch ökonomischen punkt wenn es
um den ersten äußeren besitz geht denen
der mensch je hatte nämlich die blätter
mit ihnen die beiden ihre
geschlechtsteile bedeckt
wann hast du wieder aus man sich fragen
warum machten sie das war ihnen teilt
nein die geschichte sagt dass sie sich
bedeckten weil sie scham empfinden
hier sieht man sehr schön ohne besondere
wirtschaftskenntnisse haben zu müssen
besitzt um hat nichts mit bedürfnissen
wie schutz vor kälte oder stellung von
hunger zu tun
es ist vielmehr eine psychologische
philosophische kompensation einer
inneren befindlichkeit
ich fühle mich nackt also bedecke ich
mich von dem moment an wurde es für den
menschen natürlicher unnatürlich zu sein
die beiden fühlten sich besser wenn sie
nicht mehr im naturzustand waren ein
mensch in seinem naturzustand fühlt sich
sehr unnatürlich deshalb brauchen wir
auch die philosophie es genügt nicht für
uns zu sehen dass hier zwei gläser mit
wasser und ein tisch stehen wir fragen
uns sofort warum ist wasser durchsichtig
und dann geben wir unnatürliche
antworten mit atomen und solchen oder
kleider hier drin ist es heiß genug dass
sich nackt da sitzen könnte im
naturzustand nacho aber wenn ich nackt
wäre empfinde ich und wie alle das als
sehr unnatürlich ich fühle mich besser
in kleidern von hugo boss oder jemand
anderes ich trage nicht kleider von ihm
doch das ist der punkt
wir fühlen uns besser wenn wir uns
hinter der philosophie hinter
besitztümern verstecken und uns nicht
unverhüllt zeigen und eva geschichte
steckt er ihn nicht auch einfach die
suche nach erkenntnis also dass wir
wollen mehr wissen und dass diese gier
nicht nur die gier nach konsum also noch
konsumgütern ist sondern auch die gier
nach wissen
das ist sehr wertvoll und wichtig was
sie da sagen
es heißt ja nicht der baum von gut und
böse sondern der baum der erkenntnis für
die hebräer ist die ethik also gut und
bösewicht aber in anderen kulturen
bei gilgamesch oder den alten griechen
geht es um erkenntnis wie sie gesagt
haben beginnen wir also mit den griechen
in allem ökologie und gab es den zustand
der glückseligkeit
als die menschen arbeiteten aber freude
empfangen wie wenn sie ihren garten
bestellen und das gerne tun
arbeit war etwas natürliches kein fluch
sie wurde erst später zum fluch
auch im garten eden arbeiteten adam und
eva aber es war angenehme arbeit
unangenehm wurde sie erst nach der
vertreibung aus dem paradies
auch in der griechischen mythologie gab
es diese glückseligkeit und prometheus
und sein bruder schenken jedem tier
etwas schildkröten bekamen einen schild
der sie beschützte löwen bekamen clown
mit ihnen sie angreifen konnten
jedem tier gaben sie etwas besonderes
damit sie überleben konnten aber die
menschen vergessen sie menschen haben
nichts besonderes um sich zu schützen
prometheus hat also erbarmen mit ihnen
und gibt ihnen technik technologie und
kenntnis in der kunst durch das feuer
dargestellt und schickt pandora die
erste frau eine art wanderung zu eva auf
die erde und sie trägt diese vase wir
sagen höchste der pandora aber es war
eher eine vase und darin waren alle
möglichen übel die dann über die
menschheit kamen eines der übel die aus
der büchse entwichen war der fluch der
arbeit
man kann also die geschichten der
hebräer und der griechin schön
miteinander vergleicht laut dieser
beiden mythen lebten die menschen in
glücklicher unschuld wenn sie aber
erkenntnis holländische gemäß den
hebräer oder technologische und
philosophischen gemäß den griechen
bekamen sie probleme es geht also um das
gleichgewicht oder den kompromiss
zwischen fortschritt und harmonie
[Musik]
schön beschrieben ist das im gilgamesch
epos und zwar im ältesten sumerischen
hose darin kommt enke du eine art ihr
vor und der mythos beschreibt wie er vom
tier zum menschen wird eine kreation ist
ische einfache art zu erklären wie aus
tieren menschen werden können was
passiert dort
es ist eine faszinierende geschichte
aber ich will nur einen satten zitieren
während seine umwandlung vom tier zum
menschen gibt es diesen entscheidenden
moment wo es heißt kido erlangte
erkenntnis aber die tiere rannten vor
hinweg gibt es also das glückliche tier
das nicht braucht und keine
sonderwünsche hat dann gibt man enke
bier bier gibt es nicht in der natur es
macht süchtig und man muss maßhalten
neben bier bekommt er noch andere dinge
und er gewinnt erkenntnis aber der preis
für die erkenntnis ist der verlust der
harmonischen beziehung zur natur oder zu
seiner natürlichen umgebung
sie haben also recht es geht um
erkenntnis und übertragen die diskussion
über wachstum oder ausgleich können wir
uns fragen sollen wir das leben locker
nehmen und nur so viel wie nötig
arbeiten oder sollen wir uns abstrampeln
wie verrückt und dafür unsere harmonie
opfer argumentieren wenn man das auch
weiter denkt in dem wir eben unsere
erbsünde nach rennen in dem wir immer
mehr wollen mehr konsumieren indem wir
nach mehr gieren als wir eigentlich
nötig haben und damit eben aus dieser
harmonie fallen und das ist für sie auch
die kritik an der ausrichtung der
ökonomie auf das wachstum
ich versuche es zu verstehen aber hier
sind wir mit einem archetypen
konfrontiert mit gier oder
wer es unzufriedenheit das ist einer der
ältesten dämonen gegen den jede religion
zu kämpfen versucht kapitalismus ist die
erste religion die sagte das ist in
ordnung was irgendwie ganz schön aber
auch gefährlich ist wenn also
unzufriedenheit der eigentliche motor
unseres wirtschaftswachstums ist unter
scheint sei jeder fall zu sein von
gilgamesch über adam und eva zu den
griechen bis heute immer brachte uns die
unzufriedenheit den fortschritt wenn das
so ist sollten wir uns nicht beschweren
es ist der preis für den fortschritt
dass wir unzufrieden und unglücklich
sind und immer mehr wollen
aber dann soll man sich nicht beklagen
dass man unzufrieden ist ich denke das
gleiche gilt auch für unser privatleben
wird content funktioniert nicht nur
sondern es bringt uns genau in die frage
wie können wir denn aus diesen zyklus
aus diesen hohen zyklus rauskommen den
sie ihr beschrieben haben der eben auf
wachstum der auf dieser junge der auf
dem wunsch nach mehr beruf wir müssen es
nicht mal so negativ als gebe zeichen
sondern dies ist dieser antrieb des
menschen nach mehr
wie kommen wir aus dem heraus wenn er so
zu uns gehört wenn wir gar nicht anders
können ja ja es gibt ein interessantes
kapitel in meinem buch also ich nun
nicht ausführen
darin befasse ich mich damit dass diese
bedürfnisse unnatürlich sind wie auch
die philosophen sagen sie werden
künstlich geschaffen durch geschichten
werbung
wie auch immer gehen wir zurück und
beantworten wir die schwierige frage die
sie gestellt haben
in griechenland gab es zwei schulen die
verschiedene antworten darauf gaben die
historiker und die hedonisten ich
verwende die begriffe nachfrage und
angebot leicht anders als in der
wirtschaft wenn ich so viel will und so
viel haar
was tue ich dann die diskrepanz zwischen
nachfrage und angebot es beträchtlich
sagen gut wenn das kein problem ist dann
arbeitet härter und verdiene mehr bist
du so viel hast wie du willst
das ist die hedonistische haltung der
wir seit tausenden jahren huldigen und
die sich vor allem in den letzten paar
generationen verstärkt hat und die
verschuldung unterstützt dieses prinzip
auf verfälschen der weise denn wenn man
schulden hat muss man nicht man härter
arbeiten
das ist die eine haltung
das problem dabei ist dass die nachfrage
ins unendliche steigt hätten wir vor
zehn jahren gesagt einigen wir uns
darauf dass alle so viel haben und geben
wir uns damit zufrieden wäre dies das
beste programm der welt doch der fehler
war dass die nachfrage ständig stieg
frank night ein ökonom aus chicago sagte
das sehr schön
wir wollen nicht die befriedigung der
nachfrage sondern zusätzliche und
bessere nachfrage nachfrage will also
nicht befriedigt sondern vergrößert
werden dieses programm funktioniert also
nicht obwohl es eine große nachfrage
produziert
deshalb ist auch unser
bruttoinlandsprodukt zugewachsen wir tun
40 stunden pro woche nichts anderes als
es zu vergrößern oder noch mehr
denn viele folgern aus der krise wir
waren faul wir müssen noch mehr arbeiten
aber gehen wir zurück zu den griechen
die anderen waren die historiker sie
sagten bei einer diskrepanz zwischen
nachfrage und angebot senke man die
nachfrage das problem ist gelöst
man hat glückliche menschen hier oder
hier nun nicht dass man mich falsch
versteht
dieser prozess ist nicht einfacher als
diese des readers ist etwas das wir
lernen müssen
philosophen und mütter sagen dass
religionen lehrern es viele versuchen
uns beizubringen
wir sollten uns zufrieden geben mit dem
was wir haben und dankbar sein anstatt
immer mehr haben zu aristoteles finde
ich bringt ihre frage wie wir ein
gleichgewicht finden schön auf den punkt
er sagte alles gute dass man übertreibt
wird schlecht mutterliebe ist eine
wunderbare tugend liebt aber eine mutter
zu sehr ist das schlecht auch liebe
zwischen zwei erwachsenen wenn da aus
eifersucht wird wenn eine person zu
vereinnahmend ist wird die liebe bitter
und schlecht aristoteles sagte jede
tugend wird schlecht wenn man sie
übertreibt
das betrifft auch die wirtschaft an der
wirtschafts mathematik ist nichts falsch
man kann menschen in zahlen fassen aber
wir haben es übertrieben und darin waren
sich meine kollegen in davos einig wir
sind zu weit gegangen
mathematische modelle sind nur analogien
und die haben mir zu weit getrieben
die einzige trugen die man nicht
übertreiben kann ist mäßigung
das kann uns aristoteles nach 2300
jahren beibringen die mäßigung haben wir
vergessen
wir versuchen das bruttoinlandsprodukt
und die produktivität zu maximieren und
das führt nirgendwo hin
dh sie landen in dieser analyse dann
wirklich bei einer ethischen frage sie
sagen weder müssen wir ganz den
hedonisten folgen noch müssen wir ganz
bei der sache bleiben und uns bescheiden
sondern wir müssen diese aristotelische
mitte finden und diese mitte ist
letztlich eine tugend die europäische
klassische tugend der mäßigung
vermutlich und das ist das wo sie sagen
dass die ökonomie eigentlich die ethik
irgendwie unterwegs verloren hat so
ungefähr im verlauf der geschichte und
das ist schade denn die wirtschaft
begann als teilgebiet der moralischen
philosophie adam smith und alle großen
urväter der ökonomie vor ihm sahen das
so thomas von aquin beantwortet die
frage ob privatbesitz möglich ist oder
nicht wenn er sich fragt kann ich zwei
händen haben wenn mein bruder nur eines
hat das ist eine ethische frage
und er antwortet mit der frage wann ist
etwas diebstahl kann ich diese zwei
händen behalten wenn ich sie gekauft
habe
gehören sie mir weil ich sie gekauft
gehört etwas mehr weil ich zuerst da war
zum beispiel in der goldmine gehört ein
fisch mir weil ich ihn aus dem wasser
geholt und getötet habe alle diese
fragen haben wir irgendwie vergessen
sie verfolgen uns aber weiterhin was
passiert wenn man geist und körper
trennt die eigentlich untrennbar sind
wie auch die ethik und die technische
seite der wirtschaft nehmen wir als
beispiel einen was passiert wenn man den
körper von der seele trend mannschaft
einen zombie ist ein zombie effizient
kann ein zombie arbeiten ja es wurden
ursprünglich als arbeiter als ideale
sklaven geschaffen genau das wollte gar
nicht eigentlich roboter zombies die
keine seele haben und einfach arbeiten
das ist der traum aller totalitären
herrscher wie in orwells science fiction
roman 1984 das totalitäre herrscher
zerstören wollen sind gefühle
nimmt man also der wirtschaft die seele
die ethik die bedeutung die
menschlichkeit alles sympathische dass
man umarmen möchte kann sie ein
eigenleben bekommen und dich angreifen
das kommt in vielen alten mythen vor wir
schaffen etwas das uns dienen soll und
es entwickelt ein eigenleben das
thematisiert das science-fiction-genre
künstliche intelligenz roboter zum
beispiel im film matrix wir haben
maschinen geschaffen die unsere sklaven
sein sollen
doch sie entwickeln ein eigenleben und
am schluss ihnen wir als sklaven auch
der schriftsteller milan kundera
beschreibt das auf reiche typische weise
in seinen geschichten
meistens beginnt ein mann eine sexuelle
spiel mit einer frau das ist zwei männer
sexistisch aber die pontaise
der mann spielt das spiel weil er denkt
er beherrsche ist deshalb nehmen wir
auch kredite auf weil wir denken wir
hätten sie im griff aber das spiel ist
heimtückisch wie ein kredit und wie
übrigens auch der
der macht er bekommt ein eigenleben und
beginnt einen zu kontrollieren von einem
puppenspieler wird man zur puppe und das
spiel hatte ich im griff
das ist die schönheit von kunde seine
helden verlieren die kontrolle und die
freiheit
das sieht man sehr schön im roman die
unsterblichkeit oder im buch der
lächerlichen liebe wo ein paar einen
fingierten autostopp spielt und nicht
mehr aus dem spiel heraus findet die
große warnung all diese geschichten ist
wenn man etwas nicht unter kontrolle hat
gewinnt es ein eigenleben wie ein zombie
und beginnt sich anzugreifen
und das müssen wir verhindern
deshalb müssen wir die wirtschaft wieder
beseelen wir tun so als sei sie ein
totes objekt wir versuchen sie zu töten
pressen sie in starre formeln und regeln
und meinen das würde funktionieren und
jetzt wundern wir uns dass sie beginnt
wie ein totes objekt zu agieren
die ökonomie hinein müssen wir eben
geschichten erzählen oder müssen wir die
ökonomie erweitern indem das wir jenen
die in der ökonomie agieren mehr regeln
geben es gibt ja immer beide
möglichkeiten entweder rassen gehen mehr
freiheit oder wir versuchen am falschen
ort eben auch wieder einzuhängen
ich finde es wäre hilfreich wenn wir
aufhört und zu tun als ob zum beispiel
tun wir so als wäre die wirtschaft
wertfrei das allein ist eine gewaltige
täuschung wir tun als sei die wirtschaft
eine deskriptive wissenschaft das heißt
sie beschreibt dinge wie sie sind und
bewertet sie nicht darin liegt eine
große ironie milton friedman schrieb den
berühmten essay die ökonomie als
deskriptive wissenschaft darin schreibt
er wirtschaft sollte eine deskriptive
wissenschaft sein das ist eine normative
aussage denn er beschreibt die
wirtschaft nicht wie sie ist sondern wie
sie sein sollte er sagt damit ich melden
fridman denke sie sollte des kreativ
sein das ist meine meinung meine
einschätzung
[Musik]
hören wir also auf kurzen geben dass
unsere wissenschaftlichen fragen nichts
mit uns zu tun haben
ich gebe ihnen ein schönes beispiel eine
häufige frage ist funktioniert die
wirtschaft oder funktioniert sie nicht
diese frage hörte ich auch in davos
ständig aber sie ist falsch
wir sollten fragen funktioniert die
wirtschaft wie wir wollen
und plötzlich wird aus einer
wissenschaftlichen eine moralische frage
welche wirtschaft wollen sie soll sie
gerecht sein soll sich ständig wachsen
wollen wir verantwortung übernehmen was
auch immer wir müssen erst das programm
der ökonomie umformulieren wie man es in
davos versuchte neue modelle kreieren
und dann versuchen diese modelle zu
implementieren und so war die wirtschaft
in den anfängen in den klassischen
schulen von adams schumpeter und keynes
fragte man sich wie wäre es wenn die
wirtschaft stagnieren würde wenn es kein
wachstum gebe wäre das fair
wären wir reich wurde bereits einige
sagten das wäre schrecklich melkus zum
beispiel fand in einer stagnierenden
wirtschaftslage gebe es viele arme
arbeiter deswegen reagiert der marx und
forderte eine revolution denn alle
hatten angst die lage würde sich massiv
verdüstern
daher nannte man die wirtschaft eine
düstere wissenschaft passiert heute
wir schauen nicht mehr in welche
richtung wir wachsen der fokus ist nur
noch beim wachstum
daran wäre nicht falsch wenn es nur 50
prozent unserer aufmerksamkeit
beanspruchen würde aber wir haben alles
andere vergessen werden in 50 jahren die
armen länder so reich sein wie wir
wir wissen es nicht werden sie ärmer
sein als wir
ziel der wirtschaft könnte sein machen
wir die armen reich das schlägt zb der
philosoph john rawls fort und zwar nicht
nur die armen in der schweiz sondern
überall
dann können wir die wirtschaftsmodelle
anwenden und zu dieser maschine zu
diesem zombie sagen deine bestimmung
deine aufgabe ist es gerechtigkeit zu
schaffen
just aber man kann einen zombie nicht
einfach mit einer axt herumrennen lassen
und hoffen dass er ein schwein tötet
anstelle der tochter
das ist etwas das die ganze gesellschaft
und vor allem die philosophen tun
höchstens wir ökonomen sollten uns in
euren dienst service ja das ist mein
versuch weniger genau aber dafür
verständlicher zu sein und zu sagen
setzen wir uns hin und denken nach denn
es ist lächerlich nur wachstum im kopf
zu haben
wenn ich manchmal ein wenig zeit habe
nehme ich ein mathematisches modell und
frage mich wie es ein psychoanalytiker
deuten würde wenn ich es als traum
erzählen würde was würde er sagen wenn
ich zu ihm käme und sagen würde
herr doktor ich habe geträumt dass ich
wachse und wachse und immer weiter
wachsen was würde er denken dass ich
wohl ein problem mit meiner größe oder
mit meinem wohlstand habe
denn man muss sich sehr arm klein und
gedemütigt fühlen wenn man ständig
träumt dass man reicher wird und immer
weiter wächst also auf damit und sagen
ja es ist und wir sind jeden tag im
garten das von den alten griechen stammt
eine schöne definition von mythos ein
mythos ist etwas das nie passiert ist
aber immer geschieht das ist irgendwie
schon
bevor neue programm würde eigentlich
wenn ich sie richtig verstehe lauten wir
haben genug hier in der schweiz
eindeutig wir nicht mehr bescheiden wir
uns sein wird zufrieden mit dem was wir
haben alle sollten wir aufhören beim
wachstum zu schwindeln und dann sollten
wir ganz damit aufhören
in der vergangenheit haben wir
stabilität verkauft und wachstum gekauft
wie der anfangs gesagt haben
das gleiche passierte bei den griechen
den hebräer oder den summieren
sie haben harmonie und stabilität
verkauft indem sie wachstum und
fortschritt kauft übersetzt in die
heutige sprache
wir haben unsere schulden erhöht also an
stabilität eingebüßt zum punkt dass
gewisse länder bankrott sind
was sich also sagen ist nicht nur eine
leere warnung an diesem buch habe ich
zwölf jahre geschrieben erst entstand
nicht unter dem eindruck der krise
wir haben stabilität verkauft und
wachstum gekauft
heute müssen wir wachstum verkaufen und
stabilität kauft übersetzte normale
sprache wir müssen aufhören mit dem ob
sieben wachstum sollte also dank einer
genialen technischen erfindung die
schweizer wirtschaft um die zehn prozent
wachsen dann schaffe man einen
überschuss dämpfe die manie und nütze
das geld um das wachstum zu senken
ich nehme an sie kennen die schweizer
schuldenbremse die eigentlich genau
diese josef schregel der implementiert
hat die sagt in guten zeiten sparen wir
damit wir in schlechten zeiten mehr
haben um auszugeben sie würden
eigentlich nicht für ein generelles null
wachstum kreieren sondern für einen
ausgewogeneren zyklus und sagen wenn es
mal nicht so gut läuft ist das okay es
kommt schon wieder besser halten wir uns
jetzt etwas still und gedulden wir uns
ein wenig jaja und seien wir zufrieden
das ist eine fundamentale frage ist
wachstum eine folge des kapitalismus
oder eine notwendige bedingung für den
kapitalismus
ich denke wachstum ist manchmal möglich
aber nicht immer wir sollten dankbar
sein wenn die wirtschaft wächst aber uns
nicht um
bringen wenn sie stagniert lese ich
jedoch zeitungen oder höhere politikern
und sogar ökonomen zu scheint wachstum
eine unverzichtbare bedingung für
kapitalismus zu sein und man gewinnt den
eindruck jetzt übertreibe ich ein wenig
wenn wir aufhören zu wachsen haben der
arbeitslosigkeit und so weiter und
werden uns am schluss die köpfe
einschlagen müssen wir durch wachstum
gestochen werden um mensch oder europäer
sein zu können ist die demokratie
wirklich so schwach ist der kapitalismus
so schwach dass wir jedes jahr durch
wachstum bestochen werden müssen
denn in den 20er jahren sagte man ihr
zogen in den krieg wegen der großen
depression
das ist ein missverständnis und
vergessen hat das schön auf den punkt
gebracht in den usa wo die krise in den
zwanziger und dreißiger jahren begann
war sie viel schlimmer und erfolgte
früher als in europa aber sie löste
keinen krieg aus keinen bürgerkrieg
geschweige denn einen weltkrieg
offensichtlich traf der dämon der krise
hier in europa auf einen älteren dämon
eine art nationalen hass und der krieg
brach aus aber die wirtschaft allein hat
nicht die kraft einen krieg auszulösen
das müssen wir hören und der andere
schwindel ist dass wir wachsen müssen
philosophisch gesehen machen wir im
zeitalter der freiheit etwas
interessantes wir vertauschen wollen mit
müssen sagen wir wir sind auf einer
party und sie wollen nach hause gehen
sie sagen ich muss nach hause sie würden
nie sagen ich will nach hause
aber eigentlich ist es kein müssen
sondern ein wollen anstatt wollen sagen
wir also müssen
wenden wir das auf das wachstum an heißt
das nichts anderes als dass wir mehr
reichtum wollen anstatt zu sagen wir
müssen wachsen was wie ein befehl klingt
sollten wir sagen wir wollen reicher
sein
und durch die andere formulierung merken
wir plötzlich dass wir nicht reicher
sein müssen sondern andere dinge tun
könnten als ständig zu wachsen und dann
könnten wir vielleicht etwas mehr
harmonie finden in ethischer hinsicht in
den persönlichen beziehungen oder in der
kunst wohlstand ist nicht die einzige
quelle für menschliches glück wir haben
ihn ausgereizt ich habe zu danken
[Musik]
dieses gespräch finden sie auch auf
unserer website zum anklicken als
podcast zum runterladen oder sie
bestellen die dvd bei schweizer radio
und fernsehen redaktions sternstunden 80
52 zürich ihre e mail erreichte uns
unterstellen kobinet srf punkt ch
nächste woche unterhält sich juri
steiner mit dem schriftsteller wilhelm
genazino über die kunst des genauen
beobachten
und jetzt jetzt tauchen wir ein in die
us amerikanische gesellschaft der große
amerikanische romancier philip ross ist
mit fast 80 jahren lebendig oder nein
unerwartet tiefer einblick in ein leben
[Musik]